we are witnessed repeated violent
confrontations between Turkish and
Syrian government forces for its part
the Russian Federation is actively
engaged in support of the Syrian
government's military operations un
special envoy offers a bleak view of the
political crisis in Syria which in turn
has resulted in a devastating
humanitarian situation that continues to
deteriorate on a daily basis close to a
million displaced people being squeezed
into an ever-decreasing space by
advancing front lines on all sides I am
getting daily reports of babies and
other young children dying in the cold
imagine the grief of a parent who
escaped a warzone with their child only
to watch that child freeze to death
many members contend the crisis is a
direct consequence of Russian support
can only end with the plea to our
Russian colleague to stop the support of
Syria if you tell the Syrians that there
is no longer military support to the
Syrian regime they will have to stop the
onslaught on their own population so we
will get one colleague to my German
colleague we will not stop supporting
the legitimate government of Syria which
is conducting a legitimate fight against
international terrorists how can you
justify carrying out such indiscriminate
and inhumane attacks what are you doing
to uphold international humanitarian law
what are you doing to protect the people
who are fleeing where do you expect
those people to flee to and another
question posed by the US ambassador the
question I asked before the council
today then what will tomorrow's headline
be and what are we going to do about it
the answer today as it has been on so
many occasions in the Security Council
before nothing the Security Council has
been deeply divided since the very
beginning of the Syrian conflict
Russia has wielded its veto on four
tene occasions preventing any form of
United Security Council action in the
face of what is becoming the greatest
humanitarian crisis of the 21st century
the international community appears
unable to act political interests
continuing to take priority over the
suffering of millions of civilians Mike
Hanna al Jazeera United Nations